[Musique]
il a 15 ans et il a déjà le sens de la
mise en scène c'est grâce aux ovnis
qu'il fait son entrée dans les archives
celui qui a hérité du surnom de annuaire
est effectivement omniprésent en
campagne après trois échecs en 1988 90
et 93 la quatrième fois sera la bonne
dans bourassa en 97
ce siège dans montréal nord il ne le
perdra plus deux ans plus tard jean
chrétien le prend sous son aile
secrétaire d'état au sport amateur
il passe à l'immigration puis à la
francophonie à la question autochtone et
puis paul martin arrive nous avons
compris votre massage c'est la traversée
du désert retour comme lieutenant de
michael ignatieff pour le québec mais il
trouve que les francophones ne sont pas
assez entendue finie la politique
fédérale
il ouvre notre corps montréal n'a pas
besoin de sauveur elle a besoin d'un
leader d'un rassembla compétents et
inclusif d'un chef de caisse quelques
mois plus tard il ajoutera ce
qualificatif ont compliqué la méthode
coderre c'est l'occupation de l'espace
que ce soit pour s'en prendre à une
dalle de postes canada
la brèche est assez ou pour aller
inspecter lui même le fameux égouts à
l'origine du grand déversement
mais au delà des coups d'éclat
montréalais sam ap montréal fait partie
des grands il sait faire rayonner la
métropole la ville attire les
investisseurs
et lui sait attirer ses opposants
richard bergeron marcel côté elle si
lefebvre ont tous fini par travailler
avec lui il mène en ce moment sa onzième
campagne
et si certains peuvent décrire un côté
sombre et autoritaire voici comment
richard bergeron résumé le paradoxe
coderre un an avant de rejoindre son
équipe
malheureusement il est sympathique il si
mathieu poste radio canada
bon rien